so as a ceo let me ask you a question
because leadership matters
this is a complicated question
why is mark zuckerberg distrusted
disliked and sometimes even hated by
many people in public
right that is a complicated question um
well the premise
i'm not sure i agree with the premise um
and i can i can expand that to include
even a more mysterious question for me
bill gates
what is the bill gates version of the
question
do you think people hate bill gates
no distressed ah
so uh take away one it's it's a
checklist
uh there is
i think mark zuckerberg's distress is
the primary one but there's also like a
like a dislike maybe hate is too strong
to work but just if you look at like
the articles that are being written and
so on
there's a dislike and it makes it's
confusing to me because it's like the
public picks certain individuals and
they and they attach certain kinds of
emotions to those individuals yeah so
someone once uh
just recently said
there's a strong case that founder-led
companies have this problem and that a
lot of mark's issues um come today come
from the fact that he is a visible
founder
with this
story
that people have watched in both a movie
and they followed along and he's this
boy wonder kid who became one of the
world's richest people and
and he's no longer mark the person he's
marked this this image of of a person
with enormous wealth and power
and in today's world we we have issues
with enormous wealth and power for a
variety of reasons one of which is we've
been stuck inside
you know for a year and a half two years
uh one of which is a lot of people were
really unhappy about not the last
election but the last last election
and where do you take out that anger who
do you blame but the people in charge
that's one example or one reason why i
think
um a lot of people
uh express anger or resentment or
unhappiness with
with mark at the same time
i don't know i pointed out to that
person i was like well i don't know like
i think a lot of people really like elon
like
ilana arguably like he kept his you know
factory open here throughout covid
protocols which arguably
a lot of people would be against um
while saying a bunch of uh
crazy offensive things on the internet
they still like basically you know
gives the middle finger to the sec like
on twitter and like
i don't know i'm like well there's a
founder and like people kind of like him
so i do think that
the so like the founder and slash
ceo of a company that's a social network
company is like an extra level of
difficulty if if life is a video game
you just chose the harder video
so i mean that's why it's interesting to
ask you because you're the
founder and ceo yeah of a social network
right challenge it because exactly so
but you're one of the rare
examples even jack dorsey's disliked
not to the degree but it just seems
harder when you're running a social
media
company it's interesting i i never
thought of jack as just like i think
generally he's well respected um
yeah i think so i i think you're right
but like he's
but he's not loved
yeah
and i feel like you i mean to me twitter
is an incredible thing yeah and again
can i just come back to this point which
seems over simplistic but like
i really do think
how a product makes someone feel yeah
they ascribe that feeling to the founder
yep
so so make people feel good so think
about it like let's just go with this
thesis for a second sure i like it
though um
amazon's pretty utilitarian right it
delivers brown boxes to your front door
sure you can have alexa and you can have
all these things right
but in general it delivers stuff quickly
to you at a reasonable price right
i think jeff bezos is wonderfully
wealthy thoughtful smart guy right but
like people kind of feel that way about
them they're like wow this is really big
we're impressed that this is really big
and
but they he's doing the same space stuff
elon's doing but they don't necessarily
ascribe the same sense of wonder right
um now let's take elon and again this is
pet theory i don't have much proof other
than my own intuition
um
he is literally about living the future
mars space it's about wonder it's about
going back to that feeling as a kid when
you looked up to the stars and asked is
there life out there
people get behind that because it's a
sense of hope and excitement and
and innovation and like you can say
whatever you want but we we ascribe that
emotion to that person
now let's say you're on a social network
and people make you kind of angry
because they disagree with you or they
say something ridiculous or they're
living
a fomo type life where you're like wow i
wish i was doing that thing
think instagram if i were to think back
by and large when i was there was not
about fomo was not about this influencer
economy although it certainly became
that way closer to the end
it was about the sense of wonder and
happiness and beautiful things in the
world and
i don't know i mean i like i don't want
to have a blind spot but i don't think
anyone had a strong opinion about one
way or the other for the longest time
the way people explain to me i mean if
you want to go for toxicity you go to
facebook or twitter if you want to go to
make feel good about life you go to
instagram to enjoy celebrate life
my experience when talking to people is
they gave me the benefit of the doubt
because of that but if your experience
of the product is kind of makes you
angry it's where you argue
i mean a big part of jack might be that
he wasn't actually the ceo for a very
long time and only became recently so
i'm not sure how much of the connection
got made
um
but in general i mean if you hate you
know
i'm just thinking about other companies
that aren't tech companies if you hate
like what a company is doing or it makes
you not feel happy
i don't know like people are really
angry about comcast or whatever are they
even called comcast anymore it's like
xfinity or something right they had to
rebrand they they became meta right
um
it's like uh but my point is if it makes
you that's beautiful yeah but the thing
is
this is me saying this i think your
thesis is very
strong and correct has elements of
correctness but i still personally
put some blame on individuals of course
i think uh
you said
elon looking up
there's something about childlike wander
to him
like to his personality his character
something about
i think more so than others where people
can trust them and there's uh i don't
know santa prachai is an example of
somebody who's like
there's some kind
it's it's hard to put into words but
there's something about the human being
where he's trustworthy yeah he's human
in a way that uh connects to us and the
same with uh
sadja nadella i mean some of these folks
um something about
us is drawn to them even when they're
flawed even like um so like your thesis
really holds up for steve jobs because i
think people didn't like steve jobs but
like he delivered products that and then
they fell in love every time
i guess you could say that the ceo the
leader is also a product and if they
keep delivering a product that people
like
by being in public and saying things
that people like that's also a way to
make people happy
you